okay here's the thing i hate i hate
soda when it's like at full fizziness
right what the
[ __ ] are you talking about okay okay
okay we're going we're going off tangent
i i only thought oh please please i
really thought of this because tangent
the episode yeah this is tangent the
episode i only thought about this
because i saw like
another like hot take sydney tweet last
night oh that one which was
which was like uh i i can't remember
exactly what it was like flat soda
soda is the soda yeah that soda is
better than that i turned off my
after i saw that i was like you can't be
serious and i'm just like i don't agree
with that but
i half agree with that because i
cannot for the life of me just like
fully enjoy
fully fizzy soda like for me peak soda
right
i cannot drink soda with so much peppers
okay peak soda for me is soda with ice
right because you have to like you pour
it on the ice
water downstairs yeah yeah yeah yeah i
do like a little bit watered down soda
because like
for me like coke out of a can it's so
fizzy that you just can't i don't
understand how
it is it is it's not it's just throat
made out of people
oh it hurts it's just [ __ ] gassy as
[ __ ] like
soda a drink is meant to be refreshing
tell me
you can't tell me after you down like a
fully fizzy soda doesn't have to be
cooked just any any soda
because i don't drink coke anymore
either yeah but like after you like open
it just
hear that like sound you drink it down
and then you do that
massive [ __ ] bird it's like the best
[ __ ] feeling
you know normally i'm always willing to
try and understand your point guard but
i
honestly i don't even know where this is
coming from like this is weird this is
this is coming from
i've never drank a soda i've been like
damn i wish this was less carbonated
because like to me a drink is meant to
be refreshing right yeah
that's that's why that's why we're
drinking carbohydrates it's meant to be
recommendation is supposed to be
refreshing
the carbonation is not refreshing it's
pretty refreshing it's not refreshing
well i can tell you this
sugared out flat ass soda is definitely
not refreshing
i don't like flat soda i do not like
flat so flat soda is awful
right it's just when it's like on ice
you get like you get a bit of the fizz
out and that's like the perfect amount
of carbonation in a soda
that's that's why if if i drink soda if
i want to
if i want it to be refreshing it needs a
little bit of ice just to get a bit of
that carbonation out
perfect
who taught you this this man wants to
hydrate no matter what
it just it's i mean like soda doesn't
have water in it then
yeah i mean like a fully carbonated soda
i feel like i'm losing hydration by
drinking that i don't know why to be
fair the only
i don't drink soda anymore either i
haven't i haven't really drank soda in
like maybe
a couple years i mean every now and then
if there's like a drink bar or whatever
couple of years sometimes okay no like
okay i've
i haven't dead ass i haven't like bought
like a bottle of coke
or like right or anything like that in a
couple of years
you know it's not when i order at
mcdonald's i have to you know i always
get tea at mcdonald's i used to get milk
but then i just felt like a child
milk when the milk milk at mcdonald's
and the milk carton would turn off at my
you'll get uber eats you know and
you'd have to order i didn't even know
you get milk in mcdonald's you can get
milk in it and the cotton would turn up
and
the guy that you know the ubereat scout
the milkman cries
look at me like seriously seriously
oh you need i don't know if this is like
a tactical thing to get us to drink more
coke but they just stopped putting like
water in the package deals and i was
really offended by that because i'm like
it's literally from a tap
like well then why are you offended just
go to your tap well i just
you know sometimes i you know i want to
get the the value of a meal
like the deal but i i sometimes i want
to support a multi-billion dollar
corporation
i want to feel like i've gotten back a
little bit i want to save a little bit
of money on this
this rip-off you know you know because i
really like the mcdonald's fries
so i want the fries with the burger and
i mean you have to get a drink and i
don't really know what i want i don't
know i don't want i don't want milk
either just sat there in my fridge and i
would like i'd stabbed it in a cotton
squeezed it into my tea
depressingly you can get milk at
mcdonald's
are you lagging i was just agreeing and
then i was just like wait
that doesn't that doesn't compute in my
mind because kids kids want to drink
milk
it's it's it's like the golden arches m
for milk
i have never seen milk in mcdonald's
milk
because like i know you can get water
it's not like on the [ __ ] front shelf
but like look check out our milk it's
like no no no no
i have milk i know you can get like
juice boxes i know you can get like
bottled water i've never seen anyone get
milk before
just because no one [ __ ] had no
[ __ ] orders the [ __ ] the
expiration date on this thing must have
been like 10 years past they were
i'm pretty sure they [ __ ] dusted it
off before they put it in my [ __ ]
ubereator
just
well the [ __ ] milkshakes on the
milkshake machines are never working
right
have enough milk this [ __ ] keeps
buying our milk
we need it for the milkshake machine